[Music]
we're continuing YouTube week here on
the Rubin reporting partnership with
library to bring you five shows with
five youtubers in five days joining me
today is a skeptic a musician a model
and one of the first guests on the old
Rubin report many lifetimes ago
Jacquelyn Glen welcome back to the Rubin
report it's been a minute it has been
like 27 years I think since we did this
on camera Wow I was really young that
first time Oh 29 you're 29 you know two
years old years old we were talking
about atheism in skepticism it was a
pretty advanced two-year-old yeah yeah
so yeah you used to be one of the
regulars when the Rubin report was on
The Young Turks now yeah it was a
different show we did more of a panel
thing and did sort of hot topics yeah I
was it was more controversial back then
oh yeah Burnett but we did you know we
sort of click baby it was just it was
just a different thing but you were one
of their regulars on there that
legitimately seems like a lifetime ago
to me yeah it was a long time ago but
here we are again reunited here we are
here you are one of the first people
that we brought on we were like oh
that's someone doing something
interesting on YouTube you were sort of
an early success of YouTube what
possessed you to get on YouTube in the
past oh man well it was a hobby of mine
actually that just kind of turned into
something more I just would go onto the
internet to rant about things that I
couldn't talk to like friends or family
about because they were all very
religious and conservative so I just
kind of used the internet as an outlet
to vent yeah people started listening so
for the people that don't know you at
all so you are you're an atheist that's
what sort of got you that sort of was
your claim to fame or something or a
skeptic or saying we're gonna get in to
some of that stuff but tell me a little
bit more about what it's like growing up
as a conservative having sort of these
other feelings and then going to the
internet to express them yeah I mean I I
did I grew up very conservative and very
religious I went to a Catholic school
from kindergarten through my senior year
in high school and actually after I
graduated high school in college I
became even more
just so that was a very interesting slow
painful transition for me but actually
whenever I started making videos I was
making videos as a Christian but I had
these ideas that didn't go along with
like the Christian traditions so I would
say things like this was before you know
gay marriage was legalized so I would
say things like you know as a Christian
I think people should have equal rights
and I just liked at the time that was
like such a you know controversial
statement right now it's more accepted
but whenever I started making videos
like that was just not something that
you said especially to my family yeah so
it's a-you know it's changed now how did
your family take it that you started
putting these videos out there did they
know any of your sort of evolving
feelings as you were putting this out on
the Internet yeah we would have some
conversations like I remember whenever I
first started talking about equal rights
that was kind of a hot-button issue for
some for some people but they didn't
know that I was on the internet I kept
that to myself that was like my dirty
little secret he was my safe little the
Internet was my oddly my safe place yeah
the most public places your private
place no one was really watching me like
no one you know cared what I had to say
so it was just you know I had like a
small group of people that I felt like I
could relate to and it was a community
for me I wasn't doing it to get viewers
or anything like that I was doing it to
talk to friends and find people who
would agree with me because I didn't
have that in my personal life yeah and I
kind of kept it as a secret I was in
medical school at the time and I didn't
tell any of my classmates and I didn't
tell any of my family and then it kind
of just started picking up momentum and
people started finding me and I was
mortified it's kind of funny that yeah
in medical school and have to kind of
keep it a secret that you either
that you're an atheist or a skeptic or
questioning I mean seems like that would
be pretty pretty okay in medical school
there's no way that they would have been
cool things I was saying in my videos
though I was very I was very opinionated
and I would use profanities and make sex
jokes and all those things so there's no
way that my very professional school
would have been like it's okay that
you're doing this yeah I just kind of
was you know but pretty stupid because I
used my name
as my channel so whatever was it the gay
rights thing was that the first thing
that sort of woke you up out of whatever
the religious dogma was yeah that was
the first thing that got me questioning
the you know traditional values of the
Bible I was just like well you know
maybe I would but I slowly moved away
from it I was like maybe God's cool with
this mm-hm you know maybe I'll just I'll
just call myself an agnostic not even
really knowing what that is and slowly
like move away like maybe I'm not
Catholic maybe I'm Protestant and then I
just kind of slowly stepped back maybe
I'm just a deist maybe there's just
something out there and then I was like
just eventually I landed here yeah but
it was a very slow thing because I
didn't I didn't want to be an atheist I
wanted to be religious like it was
something that I grew up with it was
important to me important to my family I
felt like it was core to my being and
it's nice to think that there's someone
out there or there's afterlife or you
know that when you die it's just it's
not all gone it's comforting to have
that so I didn't want to let it go but I
did yeah yeah let's knock out I know we
did this way back and on my show before
you had your natural hair color that you
have now yeah this is my color you were
dying it I believe Brown at the time
yeah that's to see the natural color
[Laughter]
let's just define some of the terms
which I know we've done together but our
so you mentioned
well obviously atheist agnostic and Di's
let's go through each one
okay well ideas to someone who
disbelieves in a God and they don't put
a label on it like they're not a
Christian God or a Muslim God or
anything is just like there is a being
out there that I can look up to and pray
to and is watching over me it just
doesn't have like the the organized
religion part of it or any set of rules
it's just like a broad like there is a
god thing yeah there where can it be a
there is something out there because I
think that's where probably most people
if you really believers and
non-believers if you really whittled
them down I think there's a huge chunk
of people they'll just be like there's
something there's something yeah maybe
not watching me and judging me yeah yeah
they just believe that there is more
mm-hmm and that's that is you know
comforting and
it's it's harder to debunk that kind of
thing because you know with with
Christianity you can look at specific
parts of the Bible and be like well
that's not true that's not true because
you know facts but whenever you just say
I'm a deist and there's like a thing
that there's no definition to you know
it's more difficult to you know ask
those types of like very specific
questions so it's easier to believe and
more comforting I think for some people
mm-hmm
also it doesn't come with a lot of a
negativity that specific religions might
have so there's that but agnostic is
another word that gets thrown around a
lot and and that's I mean I identify as
an agnostic still but but people kind of
make the mistake in thinking that
agnostic can be a position of belief and
that's where I think the confusion is
because the root of the word agnostic is
Gnostic which means knowledge so to say
that you're agnostic just means you
don't have knowledge which everybody
should admit to like if you're being
intellectually honest like no one knows
the facts of what happens after you die
like there's just you know no one's died
legitimately and come back and been like
yeah I met God he's cool dude
yeah people claim you know it's funny
because there's a lot of like there was
a story of a boy who said that he died
and came back and then later admitted to
all of that big faith just for the book
sales yeah so you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of people who claim to
know but no one actually knows so for
being completely honest everyone should
be agnostic whether you believe in God
or you don't because you know you can
believe in something without having like
concrete evidence you know well that's
sort of the point of belief right I mean
you're sort of you're choosing to behave
in something that you would Hallett
prove right so taking that leap of faith
everyone should say they're agnostic
because no one has the knowledge but if
you're talking about whether or not you
believe something that's where the word
theist comes in so you can be a theist
and believe in these things or an
atheist and not but agnostic should
apply to everyone hopefully right so you
put these videos out there you start
talking about this stuff when did the
family realize what you were doing those
naughty things that you were doing on
the YouTube oh man
probably a good year and a half into be
doing it it took a little while and I
think it came as a shock because I was
living
in Florida at the time and I decided to
I was very unhappy with my life for a
bunch of different reasons when I
decided to make the move to California
with my very small youtube following and
try to pursue that and I think at that
point they were like wait with your what
yeah and then I had to have that
conversation which was weird which led
to them looking at my videos which
caused some problems yeah so what was
that huh
you know it was just really hard for
them because they took my my positions
and my beliefs or lack thereof as a
personal attack on them like they had
failed somehow and raising me that I
didn't hold on to my faith or that I
thought they were stupid for having it
which wasn't the case I was just talking
about my feelings and why I didn't agree
with certain things and why certain
people who are very religious do things
that I don't
epically agree with and they took that
as an insult to them saying that I think
you're stupid and that's never never the
message I wanted to or want to send how
do you talk about these things without
doing that you know because I think
there's a lot of you know I'm my
audience I think all over the map I you
know in terms of belief and lack of life
and all that I really don't know
actually but I get emails from plenty of
atheists and plenty of Christian
conservatives and Muslims and Jews and
everybody and I find that there's a
certain set of the of the atheist
community that does this thing where
they are making it seem like if you're
not an atheist that you're just an idiot
like oh that all the believers are
idiots yeah how do you avoid that hmm
maybe you don't know that I you know I'm
sure I don't know the time you know it
depends on two things it depends on the
person you know in the video and it
depends on the person watching the video
for me for example when I first started
I was much more angry at things and I
was more along the lines of a person
that you would think is judging you
mm-hmm and I've made an effort over the
years to change that I think I've calmed
down a lot and realized that maybe
aggression isn't the best approach for
these types of things I mean I still do
get fired up about certain things but I
don't attack it as hard as I used to and
I think it also depends on the person
watching because you can choose
to view a person simply asking questions
and get offended like if I if I sit in a
video and I could be as calm and
collected and kind as I want to be and
just be like you know this thing doesn't
make sense to me and I wonder this and I
you know ask this and this and that
question people sometimes get mad at at
even questioning their beliefs and they
take that as a personal attack so if you
can view another person going through
their own you know mental process and of
like figuring things out and sorting out
their own ideas and if you can separate
your views from their views and
understand that this is just their
experience and not take it personally
that's way more effective but some
people some people just take any
disagreement with them even if it's your
own as as an attack on them which is
really sad yeah we seem to be suffering
that in like every part of society right
yeah just everyone you say anything
everyone feels like it's like a personal
attack when it really is that you know
we're all sort of evolving on all sorts
of things that's really the point of
having a human brain I think yeah I mean
no way I mean people do want to live in
an echo chamber but I don't think that's
healthy
yeah I like to surround myself with
people that have different thoughts and
opinions than me because otherwise I
would never grow as a person and over
the years I have changed a lot you you
actually I can't quite explain what I'm
trying to say at the moment but you do
seem a little different to me like you
seem a little more like confident or
something I mean I mean the best sense
like yes I appreciate that yeah I mean
it's been a couple years well I think
what it is is I'm more just I settled
and in my in my beliefs you know I I
don't need necessarily to get angry
about them or you know rant about them
all the time I just kind of know that
that's who I am and I let that kind of
guide my life and sometimes it comes out
in videos and sometimes it doesn't
yeah you get sick of talking about the
atheist stuff hmm sometimes yes and
sometimes though I think what it is is
like you know there's only so many times
in so many different ways you can say
I'm not religious this is a thing I
don't believe right but you know with
you even like you know recently with
with Trump he brings up religion a lot
he talks about the war on Christmas and
it's like there's always always
something coming up yeah
politics that relates to religion yeah
so it's it's very easy for me to
continue talking about it not
necessarily directly in a video being
like I don't believe in God but you can
make a video talking about how religion
is affecting politics in the world in a
certain way that maybe you disagree with
or wish we're different so that's kind
of a way that I can continue talking
about it without driving myself nuts
yeah yeah what do you make it like the
sort of broader skeptic community in
general because there's a lot of
skeptics I don't YouTube yeah and I see
a lot of infighting these days it's so
sad yeah that's so sad because we are so
few a number yeah that the infighting is
you know not productive well what does
that mean - if I say skeptic community
what does that even mean to you well
that's that's another thing I feel like
the skeptic community has changed also a
lot over the years whereas like a couple
of years ago it was very heavily focused
on atheism mm-hmm and now it's social
justice or anti social justice warriors
yeah so that's kind of where the
conversation is shifted and I think that
anything how do you think that happened
cuz I do see a lot of that - it's like
they were always talking about the god
stuff and yeah and all that and then
just in these last couple years and
obviously I talked about a lot here yeah
something did shift where they became
sort of the leaders of the anti SJW
stuff yeah I mean I think it's because
you can be skeptical of more than just
religion and it's a reflection of you
know the society that we're in right now
the super PC culture has kind of
affected us in a way that you know has
caused a backlash I mean you see it even
in like South Park you know like there's
just this this conversation about these
just really ridiculous people who are
just so offended at everything and
you're like walking on eggshells
constantly and it's gotten to the point
where this just victim mentality has
taken over so many people and it's very
frustrating to see happen so I think you
know the skeptic community reacting to
that is just kind of a natural response
to what's going on around us and I think
it's good I think it's I think it's a
good conversation to have but I tend to
stick more with the religion stuff still
yeah I do talk about social justice is
there anything you don't like about the
skeptic community
the infighting that you said that kind
of makes me sad because it can get so
vicious but like if you look at the core
of what a lot of these people believe it
is similar mm-hmm and I kind of wish I'm
so idealistic I wish we could all just
work together for a common good because
honestly there aren't a lot of people
out there asking these questions there
aren't a lot of skeptics a lot of people
just kind of accept things or they don't
think about things at all yeah and you
know I think it's important for people
to be outspoken and I wish there were
more people that were willing to go on
the internet and like face the criticism
that you get with being skeptical of
things and and criticizing things and
thinking you know in ways that might be
offensive to people not caring but you
know the few people that are willing to
do that it's it's a little sad to see
constant fighting yeah do you think some
of the fighting is just the nature of
YouTube I mean we're doing YouTube week
week where I tried to pick people that I
think are doing interesting cool stuff
but there's so much of it where it's
like you know I could love 99% of what
Jaclyn Glenn does but she said one thing
and now I have to make a video about it
and I got to make 20 other people get
angry about it so I can get clicks like
it becomes this sort of self-fulfilling
prophecy or this monster that just keeps
yeah eating itself that is the nature of
YouTube drama gets views yeah so if
there is a controversy somewhere it
it pays literally to indulge in that and
also people do have a hard time
separating like if there is like just
feel like you said if I agree with money
if I agree with 99% of what somebody
says and they say one thing I don't like
I have to hate that person right well
why do you have to hate that person
because of one thing they said that you
don't like just be like okay yeah we're
not the same human that one's the same
is there anyone you agree with a hundred
percent I find the phrase all the time
I'm hearing I don't agree with him a
hundred percent right to me it's the
most idiotic thing ever if I've never
met someone I agree 100 percent
including myself you don't agree with
yourself upon two percent right
sometimes I'm not exactly yeah I change
yeah that's true
yeah no I mean there are people that I
look up to and really respect and I
think they're brilliant but there are
times where they say something I'm just
kind of like ya know if I think that
and I think that's healthy like you
don't want you don't want to just go
along with everything a person says just
because you like that person you know
but you don't have to hate that person
because you don't agree with everything
they say no people don't understand that
how do you deal with the hate I mean I
just I'm used to it
I've been doing this for so long that
I'm just used to people not liking me
and that's fine do you remember when you
first like the first video that you did
that you really got hate for oh yeah I
mean what was that the first video that
I made I mean you can make it easily you
can you can make a video talking about I
love kittens and puppies and someone
will comment you know calling you a
yeah and that's just kind of how
it goes I don't care I mean it's the
Internet like and it's funny because if
you click on most of these people's
profiles it's a blank you know there's
not a profile picture there's no videos
there's nothing behind this random
username of like letters and numbers
that mean nothing like you know it's
easy to hide behind the internet and be
like hateful but at the end of the day
like that person just wants to get a
reaction out of you and if you don't
give it to them they go away yeah but
did you always have that enlightened
view of it or did it used to be personal
I don't think I can't really remember a
time where it's ever affected me like I
think the only time it's difficult is
whenever you're going through something
that's personal and people in Mass kind
of come at you and they don't let you
move past like a difficult time in your
life because they're very invasive in
your personal life which is a fault of
my own sometimes I allow that to happen
but you're giving me a hell of a segue
to the next question
oh okay as long as we're talking about
your person yeah okay go you're involved
in a pretty public breakup yeah in the
last in last what which month and a half
or so I don't have any break up to you
involved in right now well no I mean a
pub I've had to public like falling outs
right so but though the most recent one
was was the worst for sure yeah so your
boyfriend Richie who's also or your ex
you're sorry sorry your your
ex-boyfriend who's also you tuber and
public you know Twitter person and all
that stuff I met him one night when we
saw each other about a year and a half
ago or so seem like a nice guy for the
little two minutes that we interacted
actually that wasn't yeah wait that
wasn't okay we're doing it well okay
well fine fella yeah okay well putting
that aside for a moment okay wait so has
to just give you a little bit this story
here because I always think it's
interesting when youtubers I know a
couple youtubers that are dating other
youtubers you know these people that
sort of come together and then it's so
hard because like I don't go out like I
don't go out a lot and whenever I do go
out and do things
it's normally an event that I am
supposed to be at for like networking
purposes or I need to speak on a panel
or go to a convention that's about
YouTube and I find myself normally like
the majority of my social interactions
are around other people that do what I
do so you know people go out to bars and
meet people or they meet people at the
workplace like this is how I've met most
of my friends and that's kind of how I I
meet guys sometimes and it just it's it
sucks yeah it sucks because YouTube is a
very like everyone's dated everyone and
everyone's dated everyone's ex and it's
just a very weird thing so I like in my
head every single time I'm like I'm
never doing this again but then like
what do you do you meet a person and
you're like well here we go yeah
okay so you guys were together for a
year a year yeah how did this how did
the break-up end up being so public well
okay there are no excuse because you
have made videos about this honey yeah
yeah yeah well the thing is is we had a
very public relationship like all of it
was a republic from the very beginning
yeah and that was kind of his doing like
he wanted to he he wanted to make videos
and like a lot of his videos were like
my my girlfriend does this or you know
doing this with my girlfriend and it's
just I think the purpose behind that was
whenever you whenever you put things
like that in titles it gets more views
because people are very interested
personal lives and relationships and
things like that on the internet so if
you if you display that you do get more
views that's not a thing I ever did on
my channel yeah I had him in videos but
it was never like my boyfriend does this
thing you know it was just like we
commenting on the same thing together at
the same time yeah are you subtly
telling me that you think he was using
you for clicks in a certain way I didn't
say that I didn't say that well you
subtly setting I said that the
relationship was very public because of
that mm-hmm
and that like ended up making people
very invested in our relationship yeah
because like you know his his fan base
is younger than mine because I do you
know more commentary on things that
appeal to an older audience
but his fan base was very young and a
lot of girls and they get very excited
about like oh my gosh this person I like
is dating this person I like and it
became this thing and they kind of like
idolized our relationship a little bit
and they would make like fan accounts on
Instagram or Twitter and just like post
photos of us and like YouTube it was
just like it was insane and you know
whenever it ended I just kind of felt
like not only had I been duped but
everyone who was invested in my
relationship had been kind of lied to as
well so that that made me feel obligated
to kind of be honest about what happened
like see you know I I was lied to you
guys were lied to so how were you lied
to exactly well he had been involved
with several other people yeah during
our relationship so yeah it kind of
leaves you feeling like it wasn't real
right you know so that's kind of where I
ended up feeling and I'm just like
screwed
yeah and then you were sort of pinned
into a corner where it's like I got to
make a youtube video about this that's
why I think the whole ecosystem of
YouTube and especially when these people
are dating each other it's so
interesting wow it all becomes yeah some
ways accidentally public I think like
you and I was I was in a dilemma I'm
like okay I can be vague about this and
not really address it but the thing is
is like I I'm a very public person like
I live stream every single day and I'm
very involved with my audience and they
ask a lot of questions
you know and the in the small amount of
time that I that after we broke up and
before I talked about why we broke up
people were like attacking me because he
was posting like sad statuses like I'm
alone and sad and people were like what
did you do what did you do to make him
sad and I'm like Oh kidding me I was
pissed yeah you know because I'm like
what are you serious right now and you
know and then people would be asking me
like why what happened what did you know
and just I feel like okay if I don't
talk about this I'm never ever gonna
hear the end of it people are always
gonna wonder what I did and I just I
don't feel like I deserve that you know
yeah I don't who got screwed over here I
absolutely refuse to take heat for this
you know so that's kind of why I was
public I'm also like I think it's good I
think it's good to be honest about what
you're going through because like I
needed to like step back a little bit
and the people wouldn't really
understand why unless they knew that I
was kind of struggling and I can't just
like smile and make a video whatever I
feel like you know I just I can't
fake it so I needed to be honest so
basically it's sort of therapy in a way
like talking to the camera a certain
respect is it really you see sitting in
a chair and talking to a stranger with
the pad yeah I I do find YouTube very
therapeutic like you know the reason why
I'm even doing YouTube is because I
initially turned to the internet to like
talk about things that were important to
me that I couldn't talk to too you know
with people in my life so it's kind of
still partially that is cool and you do
open up about a lot of things I just
watched this video you did on ayahuasca
yeah so you did ayahuasca just recently
right like yeah yeah well a couple weeks
no it wasn't the video I posted in the
last couple weeks but it was a couple
months ago that I did that okay so I've
been you know I've been on Joe Rogan
show a couple of time he's a big
promoter of ayahuasca I've been thinking
about it and I kind of want to try it I
know many people that have tried it I
have a friend that's like on his way to
becoming a shaman and the whole thing
yeah can you tell me a little bit about
the experience and how you did it and
the whole thing well I did it as an
episode with my series that I had with
full screen it was called the skeptics
guide to wellness yeah and so we were
basically
trying different things that people
would use to heal themselves some of it
was suicide and some of it was you know
just really out there and then there was
the ayahuasca episode what were some of
the other things before we get to well
we did crystal healing which was really
funny I actually went to a coven of
witches and they taught me how to make
spells and things like that no did any
of the spells work no what do they say
when you tell them you're supposed don't
work well they don't know that yet
because they gave me they gave me a
little potion thing to take home and it
was it was a fun day it was very
interesting a very interesting
experience
I also did cryotherapy which was torture
because I don't like the cold yeah
what does cryotherapy supposed to do for
you let you get in like a freezing
chamber right yeah what is it supposed
to actually do for you it is supposed to
I mean it and it does do this it you
know increases your adrenaline and it
gives you that like fight-or-flight
response because your body literally
thinks it's dying and also it's supposed
to do things like like freeze the
outside of your skin and like exfoliate
and do things like that and it's kind of
like you know whenever you have like
muscle swelling you put on an ice pack
it's supposed to like have a similar
effect but I don't I don't know I didn't
have the greatest experience with that
mm-hm
but ayahuasca I did have a good
experience yeah so tell you that yeah
well it was weird because I never taken
a drug like I've never ever like done a
hallucinogen before I don't really do
drugs so this was a bizarre experience I
was really scared going into it what a
crazy one to jump in first you know
every smoke weed I have before yeah yeah
but I still not even very often yeah but
you hadn't done mushrooms or anything
else in that realm
no Wow nothing like that I was I was
okay with it until the day before the
producer came up to me he's like okay
you know just it's we're gonna be
filming you overnight so just uh you
know pack you know comfortable clothes
and an extra pair of underwear and
you'll be fine like wait what an extra
pair of underwear yeah well sometimes
people when they when they take
ayahuasca you know you do throw up a lot
and sometimes people shut their pants
and you just might want to have extra
I'm like excuse me I didn't
know that I'm like I don't know I really
would rather not my pants on video
I didn't by the way I did not my
pants just to make that very good you
know but that's like that in the
description okay Jacqueline did not
her pants yeah but like hearing that I
was like well I felt confident about
doing this until that I'm like how sick
is this gonna make me exactly and answer
was it made me pretty sick not that sick
but I did throw up quite a bit yeah just
tell me about the whole experience
yeah from b1 well I I met the shaman and
he was very experienced he had told me
that he has done like several of these
and there was actually a period of time
where he did ayahuasca himself for 90
days in a row which I thought was crazy
where where was this well I know a lot
of people leaves on that you don't have
to answer but I know a lot of people
actually leave the country to do it
right and obviously yeah the legality is
questionable yeah but yeah so I it was
this like little shot that I that I took
at first and it was really gross and I
didn't feel anything for a little while
but then I felt really nauseous and I
just throw up yeah so I didn't really
get a lot out of it so I did another
shot and I like went into this really
negative dark place where like the room
was spinning and I felt like I was
losing my mind I couldn't focus on
anything for more than like a second I
couldn't hold on to a thought so I felt
like I was literally losing my mind
going crazy yeah and I was dizzy you
know how you feel whenever you're like
how to party and you drink too much and
then the party's over and you you don't
really want to be that drunk anymore and
you're going to feel sick and the room
is spinning but like there's nothing you
can do I just felt like I was in that
limbo for a long time and it sucked and
then after I went through that which
felt like forever I kind of lost track
of time I didn't have a sense of time
which was weird and and there's a camera
crew yeah there was a camera crew
watching you do that and did you set up
any rules like if I start puking or
pooping or screaming or anything like
we're gonna stop taping or I might need
some help or they had a medic there in
case in case like I'm something very
serious happened yeah but nothing
nothing good I was
I did throw up quite a bit but after I
went through that like really dark phase
I just all of a sudden felt okay and I
thought maybe I'm normal maybe that's it
and I wanted to check my phone so I
asked them if I could look at my phone
really quick cuz I had people that were
like really worried about me because I
told like a couple of people I'm like
I'm so nervous about this so they're
like are you okay have you died yet I'm
like now mine so I wanted to like you
know tell people that I was okay so I
looked at my phone and like that's when
I was like oh my god I am so tripping
right now because I opened it up and
like all of the letters on the keyboard
were just like coming out and like waves
and like it was just bizarre and then
like things started moving and then I
started hallucinating which was really
cool I started seeing like snakes and
the and the shaman told me I would see
snakes which I thought would be scary
but they were like really nice cute
friendly snakes yeah and like giant ones
like all around me and like there are
beautiful colors like all colors of the
rainbow the big one was like red and
blue and I it was like I was aware that
I was loosening like I knew I'm like I
know that's not real but that's really
cool that my brain can make this
thing so for people that don't know
anything about this what's the shamans
actual role like why are you doing it
with the shaman well the purpose of my
show was about wellness and seeing you
know these different things that people
use for for healing purposes and the
shaman was there and he made it very
clear that ayahuasca is a medicine not a
drunk he got very mad and never said I
was going to do drugs he's like no what
so you're taking a medicine so I think
the purpose of him being there was
because it was part of a ceremony mm-hm
it was supposed to be a spiritual
experience and if you're just taking
ayahuasca you know by herself to trip
you know then it's not really that
mm-hmm so he was supposed to be there to
kind of guide me and you know there was
like there was chanting and you know
meditation and stuff that he would do
and so it was supposed to be like this
all-encompassing like experience that
would bring me to some kind of spiritual
revelation yeah all right so you go
through the the puking you can't you
know focus on anything all that then you
sort of have this nice peaceful moment
yeah
snakes aren't real they're not bad at
least yeah good one there was like this
hunt there's like this fuzzy carpet to
that I was like in and it just felt like
amazing anyways I was like seeing all
kinds of different things and shapes and
colors and it was it was really cool and
the snake was like wrapped around me and
it was like coming out of my drink that
I was like trying to like drink through
this it was really weird
but then like I was I lay down and I
closed my eyes and I I was imagining
that the snake is like me and every
person that I interact with it like you
know like wraps around my arm and like
touches that person and that they have
the same essence so it's kind of like
you like your subconscious like reaching
out and getting to know people and then
I was I was imagining people in my life
that have been like negative and hurtful
to me and like how this this essence
which is kind of like recoil back and
pain every time I would have like a
hurtful experience with someone and it
was just weird I'm like okay so this is
like I'm like trying to rationalize
what's going on like okay so this is
like my subconscious telling me that I
need to be more careful with who I
interact with because people hurt me and
like I felt like maternal towards this
like little pet snake thing I'm like
okay I need to give a more about
myself yeah so that it was like it was a
really cool experience and I don't know
if you want to call that spiritual but
maybe that is what spirituality is cuz I
was self reflecting and I kind of did
walk away with the lesson that I did not
expect cuz I was very like this isn't
gonna work this is gonna be stupid but
it did so as a skeptic a theist and all
that's up when you have a spiritual
experience like this does that challenge
any of those notions that you held
before head no I mean like I don't I
didn't find God or anything like that
but I you know it made me think
different if someone well if someone did
it with you and they said to you after
you know I found God in this an atheist
that you're good you know you're friends
with and they said we just had the same
experience but I found God what do you
think you would make that I mean do you
man I'm not gonna I'm not gonna tell
anybody that they're wrong like that's
not really my style I might personally
disagree or maybe I didn't have the same
experience so I don't get it but you
know I think spirituality
is different than like religion like I
think you can have it if you want to if
you want to lick label you know self
reflecting and realizing something about
you as spirituality then I guess you can
say I did have a spiritual experience
yeah but that doesn't necessarily mean
religious yeah do you do anything else
to have a spiritual side there's a book
right there by Sam Harris waking up
which is that I have that yeah a guide
to spirituality without religion yeah
yeah do you partake in any of those well
I guess you did ayahuasca there you go
I've tried meditation before because I
have anxiety so I have tried you know
relaxing and things like that but I'm
not really big into that kind of stuff
it just doesn't really do it for me but
the ayahuasca was pretty sweet
yeah are you gonna do it again no I
don't think so I don't think so uh-uh I
don't know I just I don't it was it was
a little scary at first like the the
good part was great but the stuff
leading up to that was so horrible and I
don't think I want to relive it um
people have told me that there are other
ways to achieve the good without all the
puking yes so maybe I which is what like
maybe mushrooms or like I don't know
people have people had bad experiences
with that too so I don't really know but
I there was a lot of puking and I would
really rather not yeah do that do you
ever think sometimes that like just to
be a functional human there's only so
many doors of the brain that you want to
open like I did a lot of that site did
mushrooms and a bunch of other stuff
when I was younger that experiences but
mushrooms great I did mushrooms probably
maybe 10 or 12 times mostly around
college no and never puked on mushrooms
I had great spiritual experiences and
great bonding things with friends at
listen to music and wandering in the
Nature Preserve and like all wonderful
things I did do acid ones how was that
it was a nightmare I hated every second
of it maybe I had some bad stuff but I
it's funny you mentioned snakes I was
seeing snakes in the ground but they
were evil snake I like and we're like
coming up out of the ground that's bad
okay yeah bad snakes I'm on it yeah
there something about snakes there's
some religious elements there's
something with snakes and a tree and
something yeah that's what do you ever
do you think of it about that but like
maybe to be a functional person you can
only open so many doors of the mind
I don't I really don't want to say that
I don't know I I don't I don't want to
say that you should ever not learn more
about yourself or learn more about what
you can experience I think that's really
cool and I would never say don't expand
your mind don't further educate yourself
don't have new experiences because I
think yeah obviously if you do a lot of
drugs that might not be great for your
brain but I don't know I don't want to
say that you shouldn't open all the
doors yeah so I was thinking before I
had you on today that for all the old
shows that we used to do was as I said
before it was a little more about
current events and pop culture and all
that stuff and we did probably I don't
know you're probably on the show maybe
10 or 15 times or something like that
that I actually don't think I know that
much about your political views okay
everything being equal what do you
consider yourself politically oh man
I've been thinking about this a lot
lately yeah I just you know for so long
I would just say I'm extremely liberal
and like I would stick to that because I
did have very liberal viewpoints on
things like you know equal equality with
you know rights with people and even
like health care I'm into like universal
health care I think everyone should have
that I want you know drugs to be
legalized things like that like I
normally have very liberal stand points
on things but I feel like recently
liberal has changed into something that
pisses me off like very liberal people
can like just like they're ridiculous
like you know it's that whole social
justice thing like they're too far too
far little I just now I'm like why I
don't even feel like I can identify with
that anymore I still have the same
viewpoints on things like health care
and equal rights and you know women's
rights and all that stuff but like I
don't feel like I can say that I'm very
liberal because that means something
different now that i don't don't--i like
i don't know if you've been watching the
rubin report the last couple years what
is that we've been talking about that
should I check it out you probably
should watch it yeah
okay yeah do you think something
happened like your beliefs it doesn't
sound like change that much I think
things around me has shifted and now I
can almost why I just want to say that
I'm I moderate yeah I feel more
comfortable identifying as that yeah as
someone that talks to the camera and
it's public and all that have you found
there's any tolerance on that side that
vary as you're describing very liberal
side I would I would say it's basically
the antithesis of liberalism actually
but do you find any tolerant people on
that side because I'm trying I'm trying
to find him I'm struggling to find
tolerant people in general yeah it seems
like no matter what I say I piss off
people you know it doesn't matter what I
say I'm never you know I'm either too
far to the left for people on the right
or I'm too far to the right for people
on the left so there's just not a lot of
people that are kind of more middle of
the road and if you are there may be
silent but I I feel like I just get a
lot of hate from both sides and I'm just
like whatever that's fine yeah
how do religious people react to you I'm
not talking about your family but in
general because I get a lot of emails
you're not putting on a lot of atheists
here and as I said I also bring on
believers and whatever it is but I get a
lot of emails from Christian
conservatives saying that they've never
seen just the people not judge them
endlessly which might sound a little
ironic or backwards or whatever but I
think it's one of the reasons that they
they like what I do here and I and I try
to be respectful about people that maybe
think a little differently than me do
you get any Christian conservatives or
any people that walk a life that reach
out to you and be like yeah you're not
all bad a lot it's really great and
that's a relatively new thing for me
because when I started out like I said I
used to be way more aggressive and way
more angry but recently I've mellowed
out a lot and I think I have been a
better example at least of how you can
be an atheist and not hateful and not
judgmental of people who are religious
and kind and accepting and a person that
does have morals which is shocking for
some people like hey or anything it's an
you home world so I feel like my my
position has changed you know it
instead of being like I'm anti-religious
to being more I'm Pro atheists like this
is why a theism is cool instead of like
this is why religion is bad yeah so
people who are religious can watch me
and instead of feeling attacked they're
like oh okay I can see why you know she
as an atheist has morals and things like
that and I think part of that got
started whenever I when I did the Jesse
Lee Peterson show he has this the show
called the fallen state and I did this
interview with him he's a pastor and he
was just pretty horrible to me the first
thing he said to me whenever I got on
the show is you don't look like an
atheist like what are you thinking what
are you thinking atheist looks like
about Satan yeah horns definitely horns
and this was her his like a religious
show and I was just very nice to him I
tried to answer all of his questions and
you know I think and then I posted it on
my channel and I did really well and I
think that that brought a lot of
religious people to me saying I don't
think he treated you right you know you
handled yourself well and you know I
think that because of that video I got a
lot of people who were religious that
stuck around because they saw that I
could be respectful even in the face of
somebody who is pretty horrible to me
what does that tell you about the way
tolerance is working these days because
we're both agreeing that we're getting a
certain amount of tolerance the people
that the media would have you believe
are the most intolerant I simply don't
believe it all right and yet there isn't
a lot of tolerance the other way it's
kind of an interesting place to be in it
is I think that I think that the problem
is that a lot of the loudest voices are
the meanest so whenever you have people
that are a little bit more in the middle
and more tolerant of people that are
different than them it's hard to gain as
much traction maybe because it's not as
controversial you're not going to get as
much attention but if you manage to do
so like you have and like I did with
that video and a few others I think it
brings out the silent majority and then
you start realizing that you know even
though it does seem like there's so much
hate out there maybe that's just because
they're the loudest voices and there are
a lot of people out there that are more
tolerant and understanding and there's a
lot of good people that we just don't
see yeah and that's also part of the
internet culture because it's like
people don't wander around in
real life saying rightful things to
people all day long they don't sit at
their computer and they type about them
yeah exactly that's like they hate their
there behind a screen name and that's it
you mentioned you have morals you
theists with morals yeah so I did a show
about six or eight months ago with
Michael Shermer whose aesthetic his
books over there and with Dennis Prager
who's a believer in his books over there
I did an interview with Michael Shermer
not too long so Michael is a great guy
he's gonna be on again in a couple weeks
and he's a good friend and we talked
about basically a great conversation
about in effect morality and belief so
where do you think you're so Dennis's
argument basically is that his morals
they come from something in this case
he's a believer and believes in the
Bible right as an atheist weird weird
right so I my dad stepped out that day
but you know what I'd be happy I'll host
a conversation with you and somebody
else on that boat but where do you as an
atheist believe that your morals
actually come from same place everybody
else has morals come from a lot of
people you know they religious people
think that oh my morals come from the
Bible because that's what they've been
taught to believe that that's where you
get your basis for good and bad but it's
not because there's a lot of really
really shitty things in the Bible that
good Christian people don't adhere to
and with what sense of morality do they
weed out the bad parts mm-hmm right so
they're not out there stoning people
right that you don't see them stoning
people and with what sense of you know
morality do they decide that that's a
bad thing in the Bible so clearly
they're not just using the Bible because
if they did we would be living in a very
different world for morality that would
be scary yeah I'm glad people aren't
using the Bible as their basis for
morality because there'd be a lot more
people in jail a lot more crime stoning
for example but I feel like it is a
secular morality that people steal from
and they they credit the Bible where
it's not you know where it doesn't
deserve credit like I mean if you grow
up in a society where it's it's bad to
stone people you're going to learn that
it's bad to stone people you know some
people just have that inherent sense of
morality or it or it's a secular
morality or it's just a product of a
society that you're raised in
yeah so one of the things that I thought
was most interesting about that
discussion was that Dennis was saying to
to Michael that on a micro level you as
an atheist can be very moral he said you
know he has no doubt that okay at the
micro level morality meaning that the
Prima basically the person that he's
sitting across from in this case Michael
he has no doubt that he himself is a
moral person and all that Africa where
his argument was basically and I don't
want to totally put words in his mouth
but basically was that at a macro level
for a society to function that there
aren't enough strong underpinnings for
secular morality to actually stand the
test of time now that was basically his
argument I sense you're not buying that
argument no I mean it just it doesn't it
doesn't add up
it doesn't make sense I mean if we got
rid of the Bible would people go out and
start stoning people I don't think so
you know if you didn't have you knew if
religious people could be told without a
shadow of doubt right now that there was
no God mmm-hmm like would they go out
and start like pillaging in the streets
no they wouldn't and again like I said
if people actually did adhere to the
morality in the Bible it would not be a
pretty world yeah do you find you have
any moral quandary like that something
like abortion for example I don't know
where you stand on that but like a
choice yeah yeah I mean no I I feel like
I've thought through things and I know
where I stand and what I would do and
yeah yeah pretty I'm pretty found and
where I feel for things yeah yeah are
there any topics that you're still
trying to wade and kind of figure out um
yeah sure I mean I think everyone has
things that they're not a hundred like
you know I just like basic things in
life like how do you how do you handle
things like maybe forgiveness is a
difficult one like if someone really
hurts you like do you is it to for what
is it to forgive us is divine or
something so it's a two errors human a
spring it was divine no I don't know
that's that's one that I I struggle with
you know yeah things like that like you
know everyone has certain moral dilemmas
that are you know unique to them yeah so
since this is YouTube week let's just I
will wrap with a little more sort of the
insider lighting stuff
well first off where were you hit hard
by the D monetization stuff and like
just a little bit about being a being a
businesswoman on YouTube because you are
you're in business yeah D monetization
sucks yeah my videos I if I upload a
video and I titled it kittens and
puppies and there were no tags and it
was literally just my cat it would be d
monetized and it wouldn't and it's so
frustrating for me too because like with
my channel I try to talk about current
events and sometimes a topic is relevant
right now and if you wait a day or two
to talk about it
the time is passed you've missed your
chance so whenever I you know you can
appeal the D monetization you can like
appeal and say hey there's there's no
reason for this to not have a this is
not alright this is fine this is a fine
video yeah you know for me if I if I
make a video live and then I try to
appeal it it could take a day or two for
them to be like okay yeah you're right
and I have 99% of my videos they're like
you're right
our bad you can have ads but by the time
they do that it's been two or three days
and I've gotten all of you is I'm gonna
get on that video right so then I just
make no money and I can't I can't wait
to post it because like I said by the
time I make it live it's irrelevant
I totally this happens to us all the
time yeah it sucks
yeah so I'm pretty heavily reliant on
other things like patreon or I
livestream on you now every day and
that's that's actually way more
lucrative for me than YouTube wait one
what you know no I don't even know what
that one it's a live streaming platform
but I everyday I go live for like an
hour and just talk to people and it's
you know it's a lot of fun actually I
really enjoy it and they throw ads you
know in front of that it's not ads just
based on like tips and donate it so
people can yeah it's like self-funded
and I have a subscription on there too
so people can pay to subscribe and get
additional features and things
interesting oh yeah that's how can you
chose that instead of live streaming on
YouTube because my my youtube channel I
feel is really structured and I don't
want to like my live streams are really
chill like it's normally just me with a
glass of wine bitching about things or
making jokes or talking this is my cat
like yeah you know I don't think that
that would really go on my channel kind
of thing and I feel like if people saw
that every day
they'd be like this isn't what I signed
up for and I believe ya so I try to have
like a little bit of a separation
between like these structured videos
where I rant on something or talk about
an issue or a topic or a specific thing
versus like just hanging out and doing a
QA everyday a little bit yeah are there
any other frustrations you have like in
terms of web platform and any of that
stuff yeah I mean honestly just the D
monetization thing really does suck and
I feel like it
it's making it difficult for people to
feel comfortable talking about things
that are really important you know it's
kind of shifting the internet towards uh
towards a culture of people that are
more like a Jake Paul kind of things
instead of people who want to like
discuss important things and it's it's
just favoring that which i think is
really unfortunate yeah so I'm not that
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna stop I'm not
gonna stop doing what I do just because
I want to make more money like that's
just how it goes yeah well you're in too
deep it's like what can you do at this
point yeah I mean I huh you could I've
seen people do 180s and just change
everything
mm-hmm but I I don't think I would be
happy doing that yeah where do you want
to go with all this where where is
Jacqueline Glenn in ten years I don't
know I really I really enjoyed I really
enjoyed doing my show of a skeptics
guide to wellness like that was really
cool I liked so full series is no longer
funding that no oh well they shut down
their app mm-hm so they don't have a
platform anymore for originals mmm which
sucks but you know I feel like that was
still a great thing for me because now I
have this awesome thing that I can show
to other places and I would love to do
something similar to that again one day
yeah well I know that the the guys at
library who are sponsoring our whole
week I know they reached out to you and
maybe something will happen with that so
you never know you yeah I would love to
I would love to continue exploring
different things that that people
haven't tried and you know debunking or
you know like what the ayahuasca is
saying hey you know this actually works
yeah see I'm never gonna so if I come to
you in like a week and I'm like come on
be my shaman come on
go for it but you're not gonna be my
shaman I won't I mean I
the shaman didn't do ayahuasca at that
night
you just like watch me do it so if you
want me to like watch you trip out
you're down yeah you're down all right
sure it's final funny to watch I was I
was pretty I was pretty funny
I was like whoa and just like in the
carpet I'm like it feels like I'm
floating yeah I would love to watch it
shag carpet yeah it was like very fuzzy
and yeah yeah it felt amazing
yeah well this is a pleasure I'm sorry
that it's been so long since we did this
and I think I'm just seeing your
evolution it's been really nice and we
do this more often than once every you
know a couple years or something like
that
before I Jacqueline you can find her
right here on the YouTube its
youtube.com slash Jacqueline Glen
[Music]
you